hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Randy today
we're gonna check out a video called
crazy car bomb surprise prank
I like prank videos I don't think I've
really seen a lot of prank videos on
this channel but I've binned watched
plenty of prank videos on my own time
and I'm interested this one was like
really popular right now so I was like I
gotta check this out okay let's do this
doing hey guys today I got grandma
coming over to be a part of a reality
show being filmed at my house she's
gonna come over to an interview hang out
with the crew and have some fun what she
doesn't know is I need her car let's get
a mic on her when I first met Roman I
thought he was a bum well he would had a
toboggan on he looked like a dirt ball I
told Britt the gritty said I said you're
really not gonna make it we're gonna be
extremely careful everybody shooting
he's been practicing and they're gonna
shoot near the car okay but I know you
love this car so much will be carrots -
it's your favorite car in the world yes
it is going to my silent partner will
shoot by
Oh careful ladies gonna do this I
promise you look so remember what we
said over and over shoot near it
the cameras would look like Expedia good
ready
oh are you guys serious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have a slot up front just in case
anything like that
one more question
[Music]
what would you do if excited to make
this happen for you
you've done more than as you guys know
we had grandma's car duplicated this is
a fake version of her car she's going to
witness her car exploding that video was
filled with so much emotion like it went
from [ __ ] like oh my god I can't
believe he's gonna do this to how [ __ ]
up - this is so depressing and then
suddenly like this is one of the
sweetest things I've ever seen that was
really nice I almost cried you're crying
a little bit it's like I pre-cum love
that video I like I want to show this
video to people oh yeah
it's a really good video because it
throws you off in the first half of it
it just seems like this is one of those
really fun I like watching [ __ ] up
pranks but I was like to do this to your
own ground
you could like she could have a jillion
seriously have a heart attack
but you know like I guess he knows his
grandma well enough to know that when he
does the reveal that she would be okay
with it but the funny thing about her
reaction was it was so understated she
was just like she whipped her head
around really fast but then she just
said oh crap I just put it shows what
sweet emotions were like lyin her of
course of course
I completely agree I just loved that he
gave her a car at the end yeah what a
nice little surprise to do for your
grandma and my grandma passed away a
couple years ago I don't really know my
other grandma but this makes me want to
know my grandma better but she lives in
New York that's kind of far why don't
you just befriend some mature older
ladies because do you know what happens
you know what happens what happens you
know what happens do I need to make a
sex joke yeah they do want to have sex
with me that that's a joke it's more of
a declarative sentence anyway guys
thanks for saying that was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects brandy has a channel
too does a lot of reactions on there
check it out and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can get
product placement for things such as c
2o c 2o is great pure coconut water with
pulp with pulp and for the guys out
there for girls who are grossed out by
semen you just tell them that what it's
consisted of is pure coconut water
pureed coconut water and then they're
gonna want to you know taste it yeah
thanks you know what else wish it around
in their mouth I get uncomfortable to
say jokes like that when my girlfriend's
here but you are covering that end thank
you brandy C - Oh coconut water